an inquisitive reporter probes Thomas
Harbor a brilliant mind who has
scientifically probed the existence of
an afterlife this groundbreaking
Revelation unfortunately has ignited an
unprecedented surge in the suicide rate
with a weighty question hanging in the
air the interviewer boldly asks Harper
if he feels responsible for this
horrible consequence and everyone
present is shocked when Harbor clearly
denies any personal guilt or remorse but
before anyone has had time to react a
member of the film crew gripped by
despair takes their own life in front of
the scientist The Haunting image
captured on live television on the
solemn occasion of the second
anniversary of the discovery of the
afterlife will Harbor's son finds
himself aboard a fairy looking across a
vast expanse of water however as if by
Fate he is attracted to a stranger named
Isla who seems strangely familiar to
will while the two engage in
conversation will is unable to shake off
the sense of recognition that envelops
him during their exchange will pours out
his heart and talks about his profound
anger at witnessing the Relentless loss
of life plaguing Society in stark
contrast Isla posits a different
perspective viewing suicide is an all
too easy escape from life's adversities
it is in this fragile moment that will
recounts a vivid memory from his own
brush with death a moment long ago when
he glimpsed a young boy saw on a
sun-kissed beach but before will can
complete the story Toby Will's devoted
brother arrives to whisk him away from
the melancholic fairy ride propelling
him towards an isolated Mansion where
their father continues his unwavering
pursuit of knowledge as they approach
the grand Abode Will's eyes widen taking
note of the numerous individuals
bustling about the premises Toby reveals
their remarkable transformation they
were once on the brink of Despair
teetering on the edge of their own
mortality now these Souls find solace in
A Renewed sense of purpose in assisting
Thomas's Endeavors among them will
encounters Lacey and Cooper dedicated
allies to his father's cause within the
confines of the Mansion will hears the
sound of many whirring machines as the
scientists present their whisper among
themselves Thomas Will's father and the
scientist responsible for all of this is
in a state of dormancy where his vital
signs are temporarily subdued making him
all almost dead to keep him alive
however he is connected to an array of
intricate Contraptions it is during
these fragile moments that will
confronts his father laying bare his
anguish and anger accusing Thomas of
instigating a dangerous cult-like
following and igniting the harrowing
rise in suicides will resolves to embark
on a mission of persuasion his singular
objective is to convince his father
Thomas to renounce his conclusions
regarding the afterlife an act he
believes will slow down and ultimately
stop the tide of Despair engulfing
countless lives however while will
contemplates his mission a chance
encounter leads will to the shores of a
desolate Beach where he spots Isla in
the water about to let herself go driven
by an inner instinct to save her will
leaps into action and barely manages to
snatch her from the clutches of Despair
guiding her to the safety of the Mansion
the inhabitants extend a compassion at
hand offering comfort and support to the
fragile soul in their midst it is in a
subsequent Gathering that Thomas unveils
his latest creation an awe-inspiring
Marvel a machine capable of capturing
and preserving the visions of the
afterlife to put the machine to the
ultimate test Toby will and Isla embark
on a daring mission to procure the body
of Pat Phillips from the morgue in a
moment of vulnerability will confides in
Isla sharing the deep-seated resentment
he Harbors toward his father he reveals
that his mother tragically took her own
life while Thomas was consumed by his
work oblivious to her inner turmoil the
stolen corpse of Pat Phillips is
carefully connected to the enigmatic
machine while everyone waits to see what
Revelation it might unveil however
disappointment washes over the group as
nothing seems to happen once alone will
surreptitiously undoes the sabotage he
had earlier enacted on the machine
miraculously the screen Springs to life
projecting a gripping video sequence of
Pat Phillips driving to a hospital and
engaging in a heated altercation with a
woman at the premises determined to make
sense of this baffling recording will
decides to visit the hospital depicted
in the video only to find that the
corridor captured in the footage does
not exist in reality back at the Mansion
an angry Thomas has a meeting with his
assistant Lacey who has revealed the
failed experiment to everyone something
Thomas didn't want to happen filled with
Fury how Thomas expels Lacey from the
Mansion severing her ties with the
project it is during this time that will
shares the perplexing recording with
Isla proposing a profound Theory He
suggests that the machine might not be
capturing glimpses of the afterlife but
rather delving into the recesses of
memory itself in search of further Clues
they dig deeper into the recorded events
surrounding Pat Phillips discovering a
shocking inconsistency the sequence
depicts Pat visiting his ailing father
in the hospital yet their investigations
unravel a startling truth Pat never set
foot in the hospital during his father's
final moments moved by the weight of
their shared experiences Isla confides
in will revealing a heartbreaking secret
from her past she discloses that she had
a son who tragically passed away while
she was lost in a deep Slumber as their
connection deepens will and Isla find
comfort in each other's company as they
find Hope in these desperate times in a
tender moment the two share an intimate
kiss but before they are able to enjoy
the moment they are abruptly interrupted
by Toby an unexpected Intruder who
reveals that Thomas has done something
rather drastic in a Race Against Time
they Dash toward Thomas who has
connected himself to the machine with
baited breath they observe as he relives
The Haunting night their mother took her
own life but this time he intervenes and
prevents the tragic act from unfolding
with great relief they managed to revive
Thomas and an astonishing Revelation
Dawns upon them Thomas concludes that
the afterlife is in fact an alternate
version of their current existence where
different choices have shaped their
Destinies fully aware of the devastating
consequences this knowledge could bring
they unanimously agree to destroy the
machine and keep the discovery a secret
the potential for millions of suicides
as people desperately seek to improve
their present lives is simply too grave
to Bear preparations are made for Thomas
to deliver a crucial speech intending to
share this newfound understanding with
the world and to fix the consequences of
his earlier announcements however the
weight of the moment is Shattered by an
unexpected turn of events Lacey consumed
by misguided intentions shoots Isla
claiming that she has just relocated her
to the afterlife Isla's life Slips Away
leaving will devastated as he cradles
her lifeless body in his arms grief
stricken and filled with an indominable
resolve will takes matters into his own
hands he connects himself to the machine
plunging back into the depths of time
where he tries to find an alternate
version of events he soon finds himself
aboard the fairy where he first met Isla
and as he expected he meets her again
however she reveals that this is merely
a memory a recurring Loop that Will
finds himself trapped within his sole
purpose in this Loop is to prevent
Isla's tragic demise perpetually
restarting his journey on the ferry Isla
assures him that he has indeed saved her
and now it is time for both of them to
move forward despite Toby and Thomas's
desperate attempts to revive him will
succumbs to his fate in his final
moments he pledges to Isla that he will
always remember her their connection
etched forever in his heart standing
solemnly on the beach Will's gaze falls
upon a little boy struggling in the
water swiftly he rescues the child from
the perilous waves the boy's mother Isla
arrives offering her heartfelt gratitude
to the stranger who saved her son's life
in a cruel twist of fate neither of them
recognizes each other their previous
encounters erased from their conscious
Minds as Isla departs will begins to
feel a stirring of recognition his
memories slowly resurfacing hesitant he
stops in his tracks turning to gaze back
at the departing figure in a captivating
post-credits scene Toby sits alone in
the meeting room strumming a melancholic
tune on his guitar the seats surrounding
him remain empty a reminder of the
profound Journey they have all embarked
upon leaving Toby as the solitary
guardian of their shared memories click
on one of the videos on your screen
right now
[Music]